no more hiding dante
i gotta seize my moment get ready to
cross over to the land of the dead coco
provided us with an incredible story and
breathtaking visuals but it's the voice
actors that brought this film to life
let's take a look at the voices behind
our favorite characters my papa used to
sing me that song
number one
anthony gonzalez was only 12 years old
when he voiced the determined boy miguel
he was no stranger to acting however as
he had parts on criminal minds beyond
borders and fx's the bridge miguel was
the perfect fit for gonzalez as he
resonated on a personal level with the
character me and miguel are both
persevering and we never give up and we
want to do what we love gonzalez's
connection to the characters shine
through in his performance has he proved
why he was the perfect choice for the
part
i don't i don't know
i've never performed before one of
gonzalez's acting techniques was to run
in place in the recording booth if he
had to do a scene where miguel was
breathing heavily it's that kind of
commitment that makes this next fact all
the more impressive when recording the
song remember me for the touching scene
with mama coco gonzalez was actually
crying in the booth yeah we were crying
too did you know that there are three
versions of it tongue in the movie even
though we can't picture anyone else in
the role now gonzalez actually didn't
get the part right away he first
auditioned when he was just nine years
old and was initially hired to do
scratch vocal work which meant he would
be the temporary voice of the character
until the real actor was cast turns out
he was the perfect actor however as two
years later the crew surprised him with
the news that he had gotten the
permanent part they made the right
choice
number two
gael garcia bernal wished of being in a
pixar film for some time as he and his
two kids would watch pixar movies
together all the time his wish came true
when he was cast as the lovable hector
bernal loved the story and concept of
the film as he was a big fan of how they
portrayed the day of the dead
celebration they took small aspects of
different regions of mexico with a very
personal point of view around the
celebration even though hector is a
talented songwriter and singer in the
movie bernal wasn't too keen on singing
for the film they told me like
i mean you're okay singing and i was
like no well actually i'm very nervous
about it regardless of his own
trepidations bernal nailed the character
and even received high praise from his
co-star benjamin bratt his presence in
the film
lends it true authenticity number three
ernesto de la cruz was portrayed
masterfully by benjamin bratt and you my
great-great-grandson were meant to be a
musician his father was a big
inspiration for his performance but not
for any of the jealous murdery parts of
the character i thought a lot about my
own father who was a completely
different person from ernesto de la cruz
but someone who shared a similar animal
magnetism someone who walked into a room
and just commanded attention and just
had swagger and confidence much like his
co-star gael garcia-bernal brat was
nervous to sing but stated that he loves
a challenge so he was ready to take on
this daunting task the movie was also
very emotional for brat who felt the
emotional impact even before the
animation was complete i was
surprisingly and deeply moved by what i
saw
number four
jaime camille enjoyed his time playing
miguel's papa and was thrilled to be
part of such a culturally rich film
camille got emotional when watching the
film just like many others but the part
that really hit him hard is when he saw
his name in the end credits because he
realized he would be part of pixar's
prestigious catalog forever it was very
special and very touching for me all
that crying however made him have to
explain to his kids why he was so
emotional crying with them is like daddy
are you sad i'm like no i'm crying out
of happiness so explaining to them is
kind of awkward
number five
the sweet and adorable mama coco was
voiced by the equally sweet and adorable
ana ofelia morgia but that was a
musician the mexican actress was 83
years old at the time of recording her
lines proving that she is still a
talented actress at that age her career
leading up to coco is a prestigious one
as she holds the record for most
nominations for best actress for the
aerial awards an award that recognizes
the best in mexican cinema she also
holds the record for most wins for best
supporting actress for the aerial awards
with such an impressive career it's no
wonder she was chosen to voice mama coco
we definitely remembered her it's okay
i'm here
who are you
number six
renee victor played miguel's
music-hating abuelita she stated she
loves doing voice work because it only
focuses on the voice and not looks which
meant she could show up to the studio
wearing anything she liked a microphone
doesn't care what you look like she
cited director lee unkrich as a big help
as he guided victor through the voice
acting process so i related more to my
mother
than to
both of my grandmothers because her mom
had a strong and energetic nature just
like the character her grandmothers not
so much no music
no music
number
seven alana ubak knew she had to bring
her a game to play mama imelda after she
saw how detail-oriented and careful the
creators were towards the film she
didn't know much about the movie when
she auditioned and initially thought the
scene it says here no one put up your
photo my family always always puts my
photo on your friend was taking place at
a dmv ubach based her performance on her
aunt and was glad she got the
opportunity to bring her aunt's
personality to life i never forgot the
timber of her voice and her inflections
it meant so much to me even though i was
three and four years old i never forgot
that accent ubbock was a huge fan of the
movie's look and feel the music the look
of it it's it's just a bowl of candy
number eight
edward james almost brought great
emotional depth to the character of
chicharron just as other cast members
stated almost reiterated how incredibly
respectful the pixar team was of the
material and he felt privileged and
honored when they offered him the role
almost was never given the story or a
full script so he knew very little about
the movie until he watched it two years
later so you can probably imagine what
happened when he watched the film
number nine
natalia cordova buckley is no stranger
to the screen but this was her first
time voice acting starring in a pixar
movie is a pretty great first experience
just like her co-stars buckley was given
very limited information about the movie
and didn't have a picture of her
character to reference for her
performance however she did know the
real life frida kahlo very well and you
could say it was fate that she got to
play her buckley was bullied when she
was a kid for her lower raspier voice
and she was discouraged from speaking up
about it that was until her father
introduced her to frida kahlo which
helped her significantly she really uh
helped me strengthen my own voice and
find find the power within my voice we
think kahlo would be proud of how
buckley portrayed her number 10
selene luna provided her voice for tia
rosita bringing an energy to the role
that fit perfectly luna is a little
person and being cast as tia was a big
deal for her being part of coco is still
very emotional for me it validated my
20-year struggle and sacrifice as a
marginalized artist within the
entertainment industry and society as a
whole luna was able to play rosita so
well because she based her performance
off of several older women in her family
who also had nervous personalities just
like rosita and luna did an amazing job
did you know coco took six years to
complete it was totally worth the wait
as it was an incredible animated feature
that raised the bar for pixar animation
the voice actors brought these
characters to life and turned in
unforgettable performances that made the
story so memorable which coco character
is your favorite